mmm-hmm Lars and Renaldo in one episode
that is actually my literal definition
of hell and you know I'm thinking myself
Horror Club that sounds like funny bed
vanakkam like with this out of the fund
that it's like come on Lars we're going
to run our nose I'm like oh no no no no
please no and that I'm thinking yes that
happened it's like okay it's it's Horror
Club
it's called horror club like it's you
can get give it a chance there's got to
be no expected I was actually about
delving deeper into Lars and Renaldo's
psyche their tortured broken childhood
past and it was just as insufferable to
watch them as little children that it
was as adults it was difficult to lunch
I am just like God and I'm like so ready
to give it a chance like just come on
you know like Pacifica and gravity falls
like characters game really annoying but
then they made a really interesting to a
point where it's like oh like her dipper
will that be interesting and it's just
like the these two I just didn't reveal
much except for the fact that okay Lars
is a poser who only cares about what
other people think Ronaldo is only
really about getting proof of the
existence of something or other being
rich and famous or something look I'm so
likable yeah I'm like this this really
didn't make it either way I was like
okay well now we see them as kids maybe
this will make them endearing I'm like I
didn't make them really endearing it on
I was like we're right back where we
started
yeah I just don't feel anything there's
like opened up that's I go well now I
understand the bit better I like them a
bit more Jay he fucking throws him at
the monster he's got a murderous tree
cuz he nearly killed Stephen Amell
episode um hi
I just give us mag the innocents ad take
markers I'm it's amazing how unlikable
these two are I mean you're you're
pretty fucking insufferable but if
they're a monster in the house I yeah
that's cold
yes I this at least I don't leave I'd at
least think about it first before I
Chuck your body into its gaping I would
at least give like the lower half of you
yeah I work out his system yeah you know
it's like yeah slow man slow just this
all you know okay let out a few good
things um the idea of the gem being in
the house and the house being aliveness
or being the goes like that's kind of
neat the color scheme in this one I
really like the whole thing felt like a
glow-in-the-dark at a Halloween episode
kind of yeah and even was fun even like
some of the things like the Scarecrow is
coming through the door and stuff I was
camping like oh this would be kind of a
scary episode for little kids which I
like you know I I want kids to be scared
I like I like the location again of the
kind of BioShock Infinite lighthouse
sitting there cliff I like the opening
up of the read through all that green
you know usually we kind of get one
color scheme through an episode but that
that red was really you know blaring and
nice
um and the decided that monster was kind
of me then I was legit me going like
what's going on because I've seen Lara's
written on the thing you know that was
cleverly explained a lot wise mmm-hmm
it's just I feel bad cuz you get the
idea okay look I feel like maybe what
George Lucas was thinking when he like
film this whole movie with Jar Jar Binks
in it thinking like this was gonna be a
big it character and get all the toys
ready and let's give him his own
Saturday morning cartoon show and stuff
or something and it's like ooh not
really it's like but he had a movie and
then as the movies went on he made less
less like they have like a whole season
done where they probably thought this
guy was gonna be really funny and really
enjoyable it's just like you feel like
they're kind of stuck like oh shit like
kid you see like just like if like
whatever people are commenting your rant
I mean comments always crazy anyway but
like because I found out like it gets a
lot of people are like no nobody life
and Arne
Ronaldo really is like Stan Stan Stan as
the family's on a frickin Game of
Thrones
like nobody likes like nobody I you know
I it's almost like this episode was
self-aware like they were aware that oh
man this character isn't going over well
well let's make him even more like mol
let's just fuck with the audience now
yeah let's just take two of the most
unlikable characters put them together
and in no way make them more likeable if
anything make them more apple sounds
like a nexus of obnoxious that opened a
hole in the space-time continuum of
nachos so I'm so sorry we don't like
those two uh I mean oh yeah I guess I
could try here girlie man I can just
scrape by dealing with Lars yeah I
cannot deal with Renaldo and how he
throw now you throw both of them
together there when I when she
disappears into the hole and it's only
you know Stephen with the two of them
I'm just like no no no no no I can't I
can't please God bring him back for him
bring her back you're just somebody
that's not these two um so yeah I'm
sorry we did I just can't get into those
especially renard oh it was very users
there was a very drastic park moment I
think near the end where I was just like
um Hammond from Jurassic Park just
sitting there like when he's staring at
Malcolm mad cuz I was just watching it
was just like I really hate those two I
really hate that man and every time you
see her like look at Lars like oh well
maybe if I can oh god damn another one
suppose be an interesting plot in this
episode oh really no loves yeah sorry
just just not not women as over still um
I don't know that episode will ever come
on it'll be it will be like fucking
Longbottom or something out of Harry
Potter like at the very end of this
whole series it'll be large you know
it's all about him
could save the date it was really all
about them he was the other Savior so uh
yeah then they revealed its incredible
backstory that actually makes them like
you know unbelievably likable or
something but no I'm not holding my
breath I'm sorry
literally Ronaldo could be fucking
Mother Teresa and I still will like he
could he could save starving children
I'd be like now I can't I just I've ever
talked with Mother Teresa
she's pretty inseparable to talk to I I
hear she was quite a miserable human
being I hear like you know she's usually
very quiet and then talk much and mostly
just stood in this and not still laying
down is just rude yeah like always lay
down her God just as box like unto the
ground and stuff doesn't even bother to
come up and say hi it's very rude um but
yeah I do raised Roman Catholic we can
get away with this and we were really
tight in the tradition I'm sure that's
what all the roaming some lights out
their shirts and I pound their faces
like Jesus taught me Wow we're that's
what this episode does that's what does
is - do they bring out the worst making
fun of Mother Teresa that is what we're
all the Bronx so yeah sorry gonna get
into it I get that Lisa there's now two
episodes I don't like and they both are
for the same reason but yeah hopefully
the next one doesn't star any of them
what is it winter forecast starring
Renaldo and Lars clone each other now
there's millions of them all before cast
is for misery